>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Good afternoon.
I'm Jane McAuliffe, the
Director of National
and International Outreach here
at the Library of Congress.
And I'm delighted to welcome
you to this afternoon's lecture.
As I make this welcome, I
will also make the request
that you are now very
used to which is
to silence your cell phones
before we get started.
And also to say that we are
filming the lecture today,
and it will be placed
on both the Library
and the Kluge Center websites.
Because our lecture
this afternoon is hosted
by the John W. Kluge Center.
I like to characterize the Center
of which I was recently the Director
as the place in the Library
of Congress that supports,
that showcases, and that
celebrates scholarship.
We support scholarship by hosting
over 100 senior and junior scholars
in spacious offices and
carrels right next door here
over the course of a year.
We showcase scholarship by
events like this afternoon,
where we have distinguished
lecturers, sometimes symposia,
sometimes panels, usually
in this room.
And we celebrate scholarship
by awarding every few years
the Kluge Prize for the Study
of Humanity, a Nobel
Prize-level award
in the humanities and
social sciences.
Today's lecture is by Dr.
John Sexton and is titled
"The American Research
University, the Decades Ahead."
Dr. Sexton notes that for more
than a century the
university has been one
of America's most durable
institutions.
Yet globalization, technology,
and market forces are reshaping
the research university's form
and its functions.
So the question for this
afternoon is what kind
of future can our colleges
and universities anticipate?
John Sexton is President Emeritus,
the Immediate Past President
of New York University where he's
also the Benjamin Butler Professor
of Law and the Dean
Emeritus of NYU's Law School.
He took a BA, an MA, and a PhD from
Fordham University and then went
on to do some JD magna cum
laude from Harvard University
that he completed in 1979.
All through his undergraduate
and graduate years he
coached the debate team
at a Catholic girls' school, Saint
Brenden's, in Brooklyn, New York,
and took them to five
national championships.
After law school John served
as a Supreme Court Law Clerk
to Justice Warren Burger,
Chief Justice Warren Burger,
and then joined the NYU
Law Faculty in 1981.
He was named Dean of
the Law School in 1988.
And in 2001 he was named
President of the University,
a position that he held
until just this past January.
As President at NYU he led the
University's global expansion,
opening campuses in
Abu Dhabi and Shanghai.
He doubled student applications,
he doubled student financial aid,
and grew the endowment
from 1.14 billion
in 2002 to 3.49 billion in 2014.
John's been honored
in very many ways.
He's a Fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
and a member of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
He's the recipient of 17
honorary degrees, and counting.
And he's written and
published widely.
He has a leading case
book on civil procedure.
He's written on the Supreme Court.
Nice that he spent time here, so
close to the court, once again.
Entitled Redefining the
Supreme Court's Rule,
a Theory of Managing the
Federal Court System .
His latest book is entitled
Baseball as a Road to God,
Seeing Beyond the Game .
It was published just
over two years ago
and became a New York
Times bestseller.
The book is based on an
undergraduate seminar
that John teaches each
spring at NYU.
For the last five months John
has been in residence here
at the Kluge Center
as the Kluge Chair
in American Law and Governance.
This is one of the
five chairs articulated
in the original founding
documents of the Kluge Center.
During his time here he's been
putting together a book based
on essays that he wrote during
his years as NYU's President
about the place and
promise of higher education.
I can guarantee you
a very stimulating
and interesting conversation
this afternoon.
John Sexton.
[ Applause ]
>> John Sexton: Hmm.
Thank you very much, Jane.
And thank you to each of you
for being here this afternoon.
I see several of my colleagues
from the Kluge Center.
I know how valuable the time
is, both for the senior scholars
and for those that are more
junior in their careers.
It's a great honor to me
that you would take time away
from your workshop to come here.
All of us at the Kluge
Center I think echo the words
of the great Jaroslav
Pelikan in our own way.
Pelikan, who was the
first Kluge Professor,
at least in the first class, said
that being the Kluge Professor
at the Library of Congress is like
being a mouse in a cheese factory.
And in one way or another I think
we've all had that experience.
I want to thank the Library of
Congress and thank the Kluge Center
and most of all thank Jane
because Jane is an extraordinary
leader in higher education.
I came to know her first when
she was still Dean at Georgetown
and then through her time
as President of Bryn Mawr
and her time leading the
Center here and then now
on to even more important
duties at the Library.
She's a great friend and
an extraordinary educator.
And I know I wouldn't be here
but for her indulgence
of my eccentricities.
Now she knows my eccentricities
as do many at the Library,
and one of them is that it's
a very rare thing for me
to be shackled to a podium.
I think the prophylactic against
my usual behavior is the fact
that there was no one in the
front row until people realized
that because of the digitization
of this and the stern lecture
that I got about the necessity of
preserving whatever I'm going to say
for the archives, I
can't leave this space,
so I want you to know you're safe.
But I do mean it.
Thank you for giving me an hour of
your time today, those that stay
for the fullness of our talk and
the Question and Answer after it.
I want to thank especially a
dear friend who in the process
of being a friend also happened to
become Governor of New York State,
my friend David Patterson who is
down principally to have dinner
with me and a mutual friend, but
somehow wandered into the Library
and decided that he could take as
much as four or five hours with me
since he's got to leave here after
a session with me and go to dinner.
I want to say this about David.
In my 14 years as President of
NYU, dealt with four governors
of our state and -- the other
three were strong personalities
and in some ways strong governors.
There was no one of the other
three and very few leaders
that I've encountered anywhere who
appreciated fully the importance
of education, of higher education,
and of the research university
in particular the way David did.
He would frequently point
out that it was in the depths
of the Civil War that Abraham
Lincoln signed the Morrill Act
and created the Land
Grant University School.
That's what leadership is about,
seeing the long run even
in the darkest days.
And in a way that's what
my talk is about today.
Now I'm going to start
by covering some ground.
I'll do it in some ways elliptically
because we will reserve some
time at the end for colloquy.
If you have an irresistible urge,
you can interrupt me at any time.
I'm not adverse to that.
But the way I planned it, at least,
is I'll talk for about 40 minutes
and then we'll open
it up for questions.
I want you to know
as we go into this
that notwithstanding the very
kind introduction from Jane,
you could not penetrate through
that except if you really played
out the fact that I spent 15 years
working with high school kids
in Brooklyn in and around
an educational program built
on a debate team.
You couldn't really begin to
glimpse how eccentric it is for me
to be here as the Kluge
Professor and to speak to you
about higher education after the
eccentric way in which I was Dean
of NYU's Law School for 14 years and
President of New York University.
First of all, never in those 28
years did I lose the essential
definition of professional
self which one faces,
or at least faced before
global entry,
when you had to list your profession
on the card as you returned
to the country or entered
another country.
And for me it's never been anything
but the simple word "Teacher."
I can't even elevate
it to Professor.
It seems to me that the
teaching element is the core
of what I've been professionally.
It was what I was put
on Earth to do.
So my identity is very much that.
I was a reluctant Dean and a
reluctant President in both cases.
My son came up with a great phrase
to describe this which carried me
through 28 years in such positions.
And he did it, thankfully,
in the very first year.
We had been invited
by the Tisch Family.
Now that's a name with
which you conjure at NYU.
And we'd been invited by the
Tisch Family to go to their --
to the owner's box at a New
York Giant football game.
And I took my son.
And the other guests in the box were
Barbara Streisand and Dan Rather
and people of that note, you know.
And it was a good football game.
Jed and I were pretty much locked
in our seats watching the
game for most of the time.
And in the car on the
way home he said to me,
"Dad, you're a comma person."
And I said, "What do you
mean, a comma person?"
He said, "Well, didn't you notice
that when people came in at halftime
to pay homage to Mr.
Tisch he would say, 'Oh,
and you know Barbara Streisand.
Oh, you know Dan Rather.
And you know John Sexton, comma,
the Dean of NYU Law School
[laughter].'" He said,
"Your presence had to
be explained to people."
He said, "It wasn't even the case
that my presence had to be explained
because I was the little
Sexton kid, you know.
That once you were
there, I was there."
And that's a very useful concept
and it was easy for me to embrace it
because you have to understand
that you are the left-hand
side of the comma.
That's where you love, that's where
you deal with the transcendent
and beautiful things in life.
And that's where you
are as a human being.
And then there's the right-hand side
of the comma, and you get all kinds
of -- you know, I had to tell
the comma person story in French
when I was inducted
into the Legion of Honor
because I wanted them to understand.
I knew they weren't
inducting John from Brooklyn
into the Legion of Honor.
NYU had been in Paris for 40
years and they couldn't induct NYU
into the Legion of Honor,
so, you know, there I was,
the French comma person, you know.
So you get the adulation,
you get the vilification.
I have to say one of the
huge things that's happened
since January 1st is that, you know,
I am now just the left-hand side
of the comma, and if I
get vilified it will be
because of something I
do, thank you very much,
not because somebody scrolled
something in a bathroom someplace.
But one can never forget
the privilege,
the privilege of being asked to
represent a school, a university,
as a Dean or as a President,
and to carry the right-hand
side of the comma.
Although throughout my time, and
this is more the eccentricity,
I continue to write, as Jane
indicated, and I continue
to teach a full faculty
schedule, so in my last year
as President I taught five
courses, five full courses,
and did it by myself because that
reminded me what it was about.
And it was also, to just put the
final touch on the eccentricity part
of this, it was also my practice
not to go on any for-profit boards,
that I would only go on
boards if they related
to education, higher education.
In the one case of the Federal
Reserve Board in New York,
the connection was not
obvious to me at first,
but I became convinced
it was important
to have the education
voice in that conversation.
And I think it was.
And I was able to persuade
my friend, Lee Bollinger,
to succeed me as Chairman of the
Federal Reserve Bank in New York.
And I think that's been
an important post for us
to have for higher education.
So I come to my conversation
about the University
and about the vocation
of being a professor,
being part of the University
as if approaching the sacred.
This is important terrain for me.
This is the terrain
where I began operating.
It's now 56 years ago since I
walked into my very first classroom
in a formal sense, and it's been
the last 56 years and every semester
since I've never taken a sabbatical.
So, to the University.
First of all, some prefatory words.
There are 85 institutions
in the world today
that exist today the way they
existed 500 years ago, in form, 85.
So the British Parliament,
the Vatican,
eight cantons in Switzerland.
That's 10 of them already
off the table.
Of the remaining 75,
70 are universities.
That tells us something.
That tells us something
about the durability
of this powerful instrument.
And, of course, the reason for the
durability is it deals with that
which makes us human at our core --
thought and knowledge
and creativity.
What I want to say today is that
this durability is to be celebrated.
But it's very fragile.
And particularly fragile
today, I think,
and I fear that we can
see the undermining
of this extraordinary
institution and the values
for which it stands
if we're not careful.
So there's danger.
On the other hand, the maintenance
of the University, I will submit --
this is the other part
of my argument.
The maintenance of the University is
key to any genuine feeling of hope
about the advancement
of mankind, humankind.
If one narrows it to the
American Research University,
I think most people would
say -- I certainly --
there was a collectivity of
us in Athens two years ago
from all parts of the world.
We had 12 people and we
played a game, you know,
we each wrote on a piece of paper
how many of the top universities
in the world were American.
And there wasn't a
single person at the table
that put the number at less than 40.
And then we played a second
version of the game which was to say
by 2050 how many of
the top 50 universities
in the world would be American.
And there wasn't a single person
at the table that put over 25.
So I think we could say that the
American Research University today
is in a halcyon time.
I think it's easy in
conversations like this
to miss the broader picture.
So let me take a moment to note
that I just used the
number 40/50, you know.
I'm in double digits here.
I was the Chairman of the
American Council on Education.
There are 5000 colleges and
universities in the United States.
I've actually had two careers
in colleges and universities.
The latest one was
described by Jane.
While I was working with
those high school kids I was
at St. Francis College in Brooklyn.
I call it the Harvard of Brooklyn
because it's the oldest
college in Brooklyn.
But it's a college,
it's a teaching college.
It's for first generation
college kids.
It's got the lowest tuition
of any private school,
certainly in New York,
maybe in the nation.
And it's a glorious place
where I was Chairman
of the Religion Department.
And if you were to ask me, you know,
so which of these is the superior
institution, I would say that's
like asking which is
the superior fruit
between a banana and a tangerine.
They're two different beings.
Each excellent in its own way.
And we frequently, in conversations
about the research university,
because so many of
us come from it --
certainly so many that are
constituents of this Library come
from it -- we forget that
American higher education has
as a core strength the fact
that it presents itself
as a symphony orchestra.
And you can't do the "1812 Overture"
without the percussion section.
And I'm not going to say whether Sr.
Francis is the percussion section
of NYU is the percussion section.
But it's important to
have good percussionists
and good brass section
and a good string section
and so forth in any orchestra.
And we should begin to think
of American higher
education in that way.
That will become important for some
of the issues I'll raise later.
Now there's among the 5000,
be sure, there are schools
that I would not speak about
with the pride that I speak
about Sr. Francis College or NYU.
I mean I'm not saying that all
of American higher
education is excellent.
But be careful because
when it's said
that American higher education
is the best in the world,
it's usually a much less
remarkable statement.
It's talking about
a very narrow band.
And it's worth focusing on that band
because the research university
is the most complex and complete
and sophisticated version of
tertiary education we've created.
And it deals with the full
panoply of human activity
and the advancement of thought.
But we shouldn't forget the
rest is there, the other.
Now as the center of
gravity of excellence
in the research university
shifts in the direction
that that Athens dinner
suggested it might,
all kinds of things
will be happening
to the other sections
of the orchestra.
And some of the topics we're going
to talk about today are going
to be playing out differently in
other sections of the orchestra.
And I don't think any of
this is to be resisted.
I certainly don't think that
the concentration of excellence
in research universities in the
United States is to be resisted.
The knowledge is not
a zero-sum game.
Indeed, it's a positive-sum game.
And Americans -- and it strikes
me particularly at this moment
in our history -- Americans
are extremely focused
in a very narcissistic way about
various vertical concentrations,
be it of wealth or other resources.
We don't talk enough about the
enormous concentration horizontally
in all of America and
a few other countries,
vis-à-vis most of the world.
And in a just world we have to
redress not only the vertical
but also the horizontal
maldistributions that exist.
The question really should be,
does it have to be a zero-sum
game or a negative-sum game?
I don't think it does.
I think it could be
a positive-sum game.
And if that's the case, then
it becomes about quality.
How do we maintain
quality and access,
which is talked about
far too little?
So to me, just to give you the
punchline, a good outcome to all
of this depends upon
some very simple things.
Two, really.
The first is that each element
of the orchestra be able
to articulate clearly and pursue
vigorously what the Jesuits taught
me to call the Ratio
Studiorum, the Ratio Studiorum.
What's the purpose of this
particular part of the orchestra?
What is the purpose of NYU?
What is the purpose of
St. Francis College?
What is the purpose
of any institution?
What's the purpose of this class
as an offering of the school and --
or this department, as
a segment of the school?
So the Ratio Studiorum, first and
second it -- I think it turns on,
frankly, the quality of faculty.
The faculty have to be --
this doesn't seem to be a remarkable
statement, although it's honored
in the breech -- the faculty
have to be at least as good
as the best students in the school.
You know, we know how to
destroy education systems.
You do what the New York City
Public School System's done
for the last five years.
You know, you hire teachers
that have lower SAT scores
than the students you're graduating.
That's a ticket for failure
because you're hiring
from the bottom half
of the existing class.
And how can they teach
the top of the class?
So what we have to do is get
faculty that are at least as good,
and that are dedicated to what
they're doing, and see themselves
as part of the common enterprise
of what a university is.
Failure to attend to these two
simple things is very easy.
It's politically palatable.
But it's corrosive and it's
the real danger that I see.
So I'm going to talk roughly for
about five or six minutes each
about three broad trends, and
then tie it into one final point.
And that will be the next 24 minutes
or so before I open
it up for questions.
And the three broad
trends are the following.
A trend I perceive which is
relevant to the research university,
for universities and colleges
generally, that has to do
with civic discourse and
the life of the mind.
The second is globalization.
The third is technology.
Those are three extremely
broad trends.
The fourth topic I want to hit
brings it all together I think
and essentially it speaks about
both the peril and the promise
of education as a determinant
of how these trends play out.
And I think the way we approach
education can either make it turn
out quite well or quite poorly.
So let me start with civic
discourse in the life of the mind.
I'm going to move through
this with rapidity.
I'm going to use phrases
that I think will capture the
reality certainly one sees today
in the political and civic
discourse of this country.
I start off by saying the core and
essence of the university has to be
that the disciplines that have
been developed over generations,
working together increasingly,
discovering connections
between themselves in a
wonderful way, drive a process
of knowledge inculcation,
knowledge advancement, creativity.
And importantly in the modern
American research university,
providing soul to the
professions, be it the doctor
who understands the patient
as well as the disease,
or the lawyer who is
[inaudible] and Jeffersonian.
Those are the purposes of the
common enterprise of the university.
And I say common enterprise
because the university merits the
full engagement of its participants.
And it should embrace and value
different viewpoints as long
as the viewpoints are backed with
evidence and not simply assertion.
I say to my students, "You're not
entitled to opinions in my class.
You're entitled to viewpoints
and viewpoints can be defended
with argument and evidence."
But the university has to --
it doesn't have a viewpoint.
It values a diversity of
backgrounds and viewpoints.
It's not a political
tool owned by some,
to be taking positions
on various issues.
In fact, rarely should a
university, as the university,
act politically outside the
core of its means, in my view.
Now I think we're at a time
when broad societal trends threaten
the maintenance of excellence.
If you want a full explication
of this, as Jane said,
I'm collecting various what
I call reflections of that.
I've written about 10 of them
over my time as President at NYU.
They're in the nature of pathway
arguments, pastoral letters.
They're not postcards.
They're not research papers.
They tend to be 40/50 pages long.
They're not footnoted.
I rarely quote from anyone.
But I try to make visible
all the parts of my argument.
And the one that's most relevant
here I wrote in 2005 and I call the
"Dogmatism and Complexity,
the Research University
and Civil Discourse."
And I'm going to read.
It's one of the few times that
I quote in the reflection.
I quoted this little book which,
if you haven't read
it, you should read.
It's quite remarkable.
It's even rarer for me to quote
something in a talk like this.
But this is worth your rearing
just for the shock value of it.
Keeping in mind that it was written
25 years ago by a man who was
at that time in his
80s, Albert Hirschman,
at the Institute of
Advanced Studies.
In a book called The Rhetoric
of Reaction he examines three
movements -- the French Revolution,
the Suffrage Movement,
and the Great Society.
And he traces the rhetoric
used both by the progressives
and the reactionary
in each case, and --
It's interesting that he says at
the top -- just listen to this.
This is the basic thesis
of the book.
"The very stability
and proper functioning
of a well-ordered democratic
society depend
on its citizen arraying themselves
in a few major, ideally two,
clearly defined groups
holding different opinions
on basic policy issues.
It can easily happen that
these groups become walled off
from each other.
In this sense, democracy
continuously generates its
own walls.
As the process feeds upon itself
over time, each group will,
at some point, ask about the
other in utter puzzlement
and often with mutual revulsion.
How did they ever get
to be that way?"
Now he wrote that in 1991,
ladies and gentlemen.
And I quoted it because
I was concerned
after watching the Presidential
Debates in 2004, okay?
Today in 2016 things
are exponentially worse.
Just a couple of bullets.
These are things that one
easily could not notice even
if you're not a sports fan.
Tonight, before you turn
to MSNBC or Fox or to CNN,
turn on Sports Center on ESPN
for 15 minutes and watch it.
And you're going to find that the
political coverage uses the same
kind of music, the same kind of
hype introduction, the same level
of content, frankly, as
does Sports Center .
There's a focus.
Just start doing a mental
clock on this, okay,
as you watch the coverage on
MSNBC, Fox, CNN, whatever you want,
even the New York Times,
the Wall Street Journal .
Focus on who's ahead,
predictions on the race.
It's like the Kentucky
Derby's coming up.
Okay? An obsession with personality.
The salacious, the provocative,
indulgent of demagogues.
You know, right and left.
You know, one says that
everybody in politics is a moron.
Another says the politics
is all corrupt and rig.
I mean, it's the same kind of
broad-stroke demagoguery in my view.
So nice to be, after January 1st,
when I'm not a comma person anymore
and I can just tell you what I
think about things like this.
Very little attention to the issues.
Still less to what we
in competitive debate --
my book on high school kids know
that if you don't extend
the argument, you know,
the first negative makes a point,
the second affirmative
has to extend on that.
Then the second negative and
into the rebuttals, right?
It doesn't happen, doesn't happen.
Just stay away from this year.
I'll use an example from 2004.
John Edwards, remember him?
Serious candidate.
Forty debates I watched.
In every one of those 40 debates
he said, "I grew up in a mill town.
My father lost his job.
I didn't vote for NAFTA."
One of my Brooklyn High
School girls would have asked
in first course examination,
"Would you repeat NAFTA, Senator?"
He was never asked that
question in debates.
He was asked two-thirds of
the way through the campaign
by the New York Times
Editorial Board, and he said,
"Of course I wouldn't repeal NAFTA."
What just happened to
your campaign, Senator?
Okay. But we don't extend arguments.
And there's such a
devaluation of seriousness
that you actually hear
experts saying that a person
that takes issue seriously and
gets into detail and nuance
and complexity, by virtue of
doing that lacks charisma.
Right? So that's the
ultimate critique, isn't it?
So we've developed, as a society,
a shrinking attention span.
We've allyded [assumed
spelling] news and entertainment.
We've got a coliseum culture that
we've developed, and an allergy
to nuance and complexity.
Ladies, and gentlemen, what
do research universities do?
We do nuance and complexity.
This is not good for us, okay?
This portends, I am telling
you, an evitable working
out over the next generation, with
no end in sight, of a disinvestment
in education generally,
in high higher education.
That has to come from a society that
is making thought an accusation.
You think too much.
Less investment in research,
less investment in education
as a public good, and, certainly,
scapegoating as to
the results, right?
So even as the money is withdrawn
from subsidizing the cost
of higher education,
we scapegoat those
who are running higher education.
The money's gone away.
Oh, by the way, one of the
solutions we'll do is we'll increase
compliance reporting.
So you have to hire more people and
then we will point to the increase
in the number of administrators.
Okay. You're looking at the
President of one of the 20 colleges
and universities that was chosen,
quote, at random, close quote,
by Senator Grassley
for a full IRS audit.
Just at random, you know, like the
little thing that goes off with TSA.
And a year-and-a-half, four IRS
offices at NYU day in and day out.
Imagine the administrative
time consumed by that.
We got a clean bill
of health in the end.
But a year-and-a-half.
And then, you know, we,
ourselves, undermine the ideal.
I was, of course, a
member of the Association
of American Universities
beginning in 2001.
And as we began to launch
a major justification
of the research university
with the Norm Augustine report,
"Rising Above the Gathering Storm,"
I argued as vigorously I could,
to no effect, that this
was a Faustian bargain,
that if you start justifying
what universities do
on a basic utilitarianism,
you're going to run directly
into undermining yourself as
there's an impact on the humanities,
and then the social sciences,
and then on basic research
in the sciences, and
creativity goes off the agenda.
And short term results
become important.
Now, that's the dark side.
It's still the case that our
universities are the greatest
counterforce to these
activities and these trends.
Or at least they can be.
It requires profiles in courage.
This is a moment where
we have to stand up,
where we have to sing
the song of thought.
And we have to start honoring people
who engage in serious conversation
and we have to shame
those who don't.
And we have to figure out vehicles.
And I suggest some in my reflection.
We have to figure out vehicles
whereby to do that with consortia
that essentially say, people are --
you know, like the Pinocchio stuff,
but on a more serious level.
Are people engaging in
serious conversation?
Okay. So there's a dogmatism
that's developing an allergy
to nuance and complexity.
That's not good for universities.
But if we have the courage to step
forward and we see it coming --
we have been around for
more than 500 years.
We are -- we do do thought.
That is what makes us human.
What about globalization?
I'm going to be brief on this and
technology because I want to get
to the questions, and I do want to
reserve some time for my windup.
So, on globalization.
Look, hello, here I am.
PhD in Religion, Fordham, in
college for four to five years
at a Vatican Council,
then getting my PhD
in the wake of the Vatican Council.
The word ecumenism
means something to me.
Okay. It means, when you translate
it into the secular sphere,
that there's a big premium that you
receive if you can look at life,
not through the one window
you're given at birth,
but through the many windows in
the many rooms of the mansion.
This is the ecumenical, the
secular ecumenical mindset.
Globalization is happening.
And I'm not just talking
about economic globalization.
I mean the other is in our lives.
The world is miniaturizing.
The question is, how
do we respond to it?
And there were two responses.
One is building on the elegy
to nuance and complexity,
the devaluation of thought, is
to move to a competitiveness we
versus they rationale, around a
world, most recently in Austria.
You see the answer in
neon signs, "Let me alone.
Let me live with folks like me."
You see the response of
essentially building up walls.
We don't put in the hard work
of understanding globalization.
My cousins, who are carpenters
and electricians and real workers,
you know, people that really
do things and I adore them
and I adore their values as human
beings, but they want to shop
at Walmart and Costco even as they
complain about the jobs leaving
that are creating the products that
they're getting at a lesser price
because the jobs have left, so --
and no one wants to get into
the genuineness of that.
And the problem is, in
part, that there is a face
on the negative effect
of globalization,
whereas there's no face on --
maybe the closest is Pope Francis.
But think, is there a world leader
out there that's stepping out
and explaining globalization?
The answer's no.
So reaction one is fear,
negativism, protectionism.
Reaction two, which is, by the
way, where universities have been
through the centuries, has been
the ecumenical reaction, okay?
Embrace engagement, see
the gifts of difference,
and the other as a great
gift to be studied.
The choice is for or
against common enterprise.
And I would submit
to you that, again,
universities are the key here.
The universities have
always been global.
There's always been a
world community of ideas.
Universities have been about
communication and understanding.
Increasingly the world
is developing a network
of what I call idea capitals, ideals
capitals that are animated not only
by the old things -- FIRE,
FIRE, finance, insurance,
and real estate -- but a
new element that's necessary
for the modern idea
capital, the intellectual,
cultural, and educational, ICE.
We have to FIRE and ICE together.
And universities are in
the FIRE and ICE business.
We do ICE.
We do the intellectual,
cultural, and educational.
Now, how universities will respond
to globalization and embrace
that notion of ecumenism
in the [inaudible].
We have many, many different ones.
I mean, NYU is all in,
but others will do it
through bilateral arrangements,
associations
and consortia, co-chairing.
There are any number
of ways to do it.
But most of all, we have
to model a set of things
as we address globalization.
We, the university community,
we have to model the celebration
of thought, the positive-sum
consequences
of common enterprise
and cooperation.
This means maybe coopetition, if not
cooperation, but not competition.
It's not seeing it as zero-sum.
It means sharing.
Sufferings is to technology.
Technology will be, as they
say, disruptive insofar
as it will cause change
in many areas.
But it's easy to overstate
the degree of disruption
that technology will
cause in higher education.
Those who make a major
claim of disruption tend
to have a very narrow
understanding of what education is.
They see it principally as
information acquisition.
And there'll be parts
of the orchestra
where that will be significant,
but not the part of the orchestra
in which the research university
does most of its operation.
I'm going to get more
concrete on this in a moment.
But I mean, look, my life now,
in addition to my being a faculty
member at NYU, is occupied trying
to bring education to kids around
the world -- primary, secondary,
and tertiary -- who
just don't have a shot
at a meaningful education today.
Want to hear a scary number?
Eight-five million, 85 million
primary and secondary-age children
in the world will go through
life, unless we change things,
never having met a teacher.
Nobody's even trying to
educate them, you know?
And some of them are in cities
in India or Brazil, in the slums.
Some of them are in remote areas.
Some of them are in warzones.
Some of them are in
abjectly poor countries.
Some of them are in refugee
camps where, once a kid gets
to a refugee camp,
the average time he
or she is there is 10 years, okay?
Eight-five million kids
never meet a teacher.
Another 260 million, even if they
get a stamp that says they graduated
from high school, won't
be able to read.
They have a fourth-grade
reading level.
So, you know, technology
can help a lot, okay?
But it's not a panacea
even for those kids.
That's where I'll end.
But the key is, would
we want our kids
to have what those kids
are likely to have?
Yeah, we have people in this country
saying to the poor, the uninformed,
the unconnected, send your kid
to an online school,
$10,000 college degree.
And those same people are paying
tutors to prepare the kids
for the SAT so that they can
get into a list of 20 or 30
or 40 schools that I guarantee
you are not online schools.
So we have to be a little bit, you
know, Rawlsian about this, right?
A little John Rawls here.
Am I advising others to do
what I would do with my kids?
This is, you know, the
educational version of fighting wars
with other people's children.
The argument is made, though, what
-- even in the research university,
technology or, you know, it will
help address this issue of cost,
you know, cost is going
up, it's going up.
We've got to suppress cost.
Well, yeah, there are
places, I could tell you.
You know, we -- I have lived for
the last five years for a budget
with an annual operating
budget north
of $7 billion a year
throughout my [inaudible].
I think we started
at $5 billion a year.
These are big budgets, you know.
Can you save money with
technology in them?
Sure, you know.
In fact, we managed to
save a good bit of money.
But what about in the
academic sense?
Well, yeah, there are places.
You know, Language
101 courses, you know.
The most basic language courses.
You could save money there by
doing it technologically rather
than with a professor or a
supplement of professors.
But most of the areas where
you would integrate technology
into the research university either
do not save money or drive costs up.
So to flip a classroom makes the
experience in the classroom better
by having the kids to technological
exercise before they come.
But it doesn't save money, okay?
In fact, when you think about it,
at the really top universities,
the ones we're talking about when
we use the word research university.
I mean I can't -- at
my Tisch Film School,
I can't have a camera
for more than two years.
Otherwise I'm not training
the kids for the industry.
So there's a technological
half-life, you know.
The first decision I had
to make as President was,
you know, you go for an MRI.
There's a 1.5 Tesla Machine
that reads you for the doctor.
Research university, it's a
3 Tesla Machine which is --
it's logarithmic so it's much
more than twice as powerful, okay?
My guys wanted the only 7
Tesla Machine in the country.
Seven Tesla.
"How much does that cost,
Bob," I said to the Dean.
Forty million dollars.
This does not save money, okay?
Now, it might cure
diseases more quickly.
Technology does not save money
at research universities,
net, net, net, net, net.
So the biggest impact of
technology in my view,
and this is where I'll close on this
and segue to my final punchline.
The biggest impact is, frankly,
when it's rarely mentioned.
I think everything from the mooks
to something called the
University of the People.
Now I'm Chairman of the Board
at the University of the People.
I've been Chairman for seven years.
What's the University of the People?
Well, if you're a high school
graduate, you're fluent in English,
you have access to the Internet,
and you are abjectly poor,
you're automatically admitted.
Welcome aboard, no matter
where you are in the world.
And you'll get an accredited
in the United States,
accredited, free college education.
Here it is.
All open source materials.
You sign up for courses.
There are volunteer professors that
have made up the curriculum and work
with the 32 students in the class
that do peer-peer learning largely.
And then they get the final exam
and they take a secure final exam
and they get a grade and they've
now passed, you know, English 10.
And you aggregate your 36 courses
just the way you would in a college
if you were in Amherst
or New York City
or Washington, D.C.,
and you graduate.
You've got an accredited degree.
We had the graduation ceremony for
our first seven students last year.
But we're now up to 3000 students.
And that's technology
doing something good.
But, but, but, but,
now wait a minute.
What about this Rawlsian thing?
What about these other people's
children thing, you know?
Would you send your Jed or
your Katie, your children,
to the University of the People?
No. And we shouldn't trap anybody in
the University of the People either.
So what we've started
to do, and so far,
we've got three cooperating
universities --
NYU, Berkeley, and
University College London --
that at the end of the
first year, the University
of the People will look at the top
10% of the class for transfer in
and now you're moving up a ladder.
Thank you very much.
Now maybe the first step would
be the St. Francis College
when we get this thing
going worldwide.
But use technology and things
like the University of the People,
things like mooks, as
search engines for talent.
But then make the ladders
up available.
That's the way technology
could be used.
And this brings me to my
fourth and final topic.
That is this.
There's peril and promise in
what I see in the decades ahead.
The peril is that, as we've
seen work out in so many areas,
that now higher education, formerly
the instrument of opportunity,
will become the way to lock in a
caste system that is more powerful
than any caste system ever
created by a religion,
where we send the children
of the poor, the uninformed,
the unconnected, to
$10,000 online colleges
where they neither get the quality
of education that we understand
at some level, the kids at St.
Francis and at NYU and at Georgetown
and at Harvard are getting.
You know, we get that.
You know, there's something
going [inaudible] because that's
where we want to send our kids.
You know, I come from a city
where people pay $35,000
a year for kindergarten.
And they fight the people that have
all the knowledge and all the money
and all the connections
to get their kids in.
What do they know?
Okay? It's so simple.
Just will you do it for your kids?
And the fear is that, you know,
in the past the elites would
give a fortune to their kids
and there was some chance
their kids would squander it.
But now we're giving kids
of the elite's education
that others aren't getting and
we're giving them a network
of relationships that
comes from that education,
at least if it's not online.
So what's the answer?
Well, I think the answer is to push
the quality of our higher education
as far as we can, paying attention
to the issues I've put on the table.
But it's also to make sure that
everybody has access and information
and the capacity to
climb ladders up.
So, I would create literally
a worldwide clearinghouse
of educational opportunity.
I'm involved now with an effort
with Former Prime Minister
Gordon Brown to do just that.
And I think that we will have
the college version of that up
and running within a year.
And we intend to try to do it
for all levels of education.
I think that we then
have to supplant that,
because you can't expect many of
the kids out there that are as good
as any kids that are in the best
schools anywhere in the world, okay?
That's the thing I want
you to understand, okay?
I want you to know, and excuse
me just for giving one example,
because we've run this
experiment with NYU Abu Dhabi,
where we were sent out with the
ability to find kids that were
as good as any in the world.
That was the admission
standard for NYU Abu Dhabi.
Clearly admissible to
any school in the world.
Far higher than the admission
standard for NYU New York.
So we found Moosebah
[assumed spelling].
Who is Moosebah?
Moosebah homeschooled himself
grades one through eight
in tribal village in Ethiopia.
He walked five days to Addis
Ababa, knocked on the door
of the International School, and
said, give me any test you want.
I want to be in your school.
He got the highest grades
in the entrance exams.
They gave him a spot
and a scholarship.
They didn't find out for six
months he was living alone
as a 13-year-old in the airport.
And they gave him housing
at that point, and food.
He graduated at the
top of his class,
came as part of the first
graduating class to NYU Abu Dhabi.
Graduated magna cum laude along
with the best kids in the world.
He was not alone in that
first class of 150 kids
with that kind of profile.
Twenty percent of the class
had that kind of profile.
Those kids could have been wasted.
What I'm saying is we have
to get out and we have to --
we won't always have, you know,
a Sheikh Mohammed bin
Zayed who's willing to pay
for Moosebah's education or
Teyho's [assumed spelling] education
or the education of the now more
than a hundred kids of that ilk
that have graduated
from that one school.
We've got to generalize this.
And that means we have to have
something like Teacher America,
except guidance counsellors
for America that have to be
out there showing kids
how to get through.
And not just guidance
counsellors for America
but guidance counsellors
for the world.
And then the question is,
after the match is made --
and we have a serious
problem of undermatching
in the United States --
[inaudible] in the world, okay.
But just focus on the United States.
Okay. Systematically -- read
Bill Bowen's work on this.
Systematically, when you control
for everything, kids that come
from lower socioeconomic groups
go to colleges that are less good
than the colleges they should go to.
Controlling for everything.
And when they get to
the less good place,
when they're matched less
well, they do less well.
Why? Because they're
not as stimulated.
They want the support
services, right?
All that stuff.
It just flows.
It's weird.
It happens in part because you
have political leaders saying go
to a $10,000 online school.
So they think only about the price.
You'd say community
college is going to be free.
Oh, that's a bargain.
So you end up going to a community
college in your area instead
of investigating further.
Or maybe you do investigate
further and you make it
into the school you
should make it into.
But then some less good school comes
along, gives you a scholarship,
and buys you down in a way.
I mean, the system is perverse.
And it's a system of a lack of
transparency, a lack of information,
a lack of guidance,
and then, finally,
a lack of an ability
to pay in the end.
And that's where we've
got to take seriously --
we're never going to get back
to the time that I grew up in.
And I wouldn't have gone to
college if it hadn't been
for Nelson Rockefeller and his view
that higher education
was a public good.
And if you were a smart kid, you
got a regent state scholarship.
And as long as you went to school
in New York State, it was for free.
Public or private.
You found the best school for you.
For me it was Fordham.
It was a private school.
But my tuition was covered
by my state scholarship
because higher education
was a public good.
Ronald Reagan changed that.
Right now, higher education
gives you this private good.
You borrow.
We got to get it back to at
least the quasi-public good.
That's where I'm trying to go.
So the pay-as-you-earn program.
This is not something
I thought up, okay?
It's done in Australia.
It's done in the U.K. now.
Argonne has started it.
The Brookings Institute
has great stuff on it.
I would go farther than any
of those have gone however.
I would say essentially what
Nelson Rockefeller said,
but I would treat -- you
find a school, you go to it,
we'll pay for it, you pay
the loan back over 20 years
but you never have to pay more than
10% of your income over $50,000.
The first $50,000 you don't
pay anything off, okay?
So the key is about matching
and then capacitating.
Matching and then capacitating.
Now, if we do that, starting in
this country, and then we do it
in the world, then circling back,
I think we got a chance, a chance.
But, you know, we all
have to play Don Quixote.
Okay? This is -- call
it the [inaudible].
I'll be a theologian here again.
This is the educational
version of Pascal's Wager.
It's no sense betting
against ourselves here.
If we do this, we can have a chance
to turn back this creeping dogmatism
that is killing civil
discourse, and going to kill us
as a nation if we're not careful.
We've got a chance of
turning globalization
into the positive it should be
-- a genuine ecumenical world,
a community of communities,
into locking each identifiable
like the elements of a watch,
but creating something greater
than the whole of the parts.
And we've got a chance
to use technology well.
Thank you all for your attention.
I appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
Should we do questions or --
>> Jane McAuliffe: Well,
I promised to stimulating.
And I think John delivered.
We've got time for probably
about 10 minutes of Q&A.
We have microphones.
So let the first brave
person [inaudible].
>> John Sexton: It would be nice
if you could just tell
me who you are, sir.
>> Yeah. My name is Gregory Gums.
I'm from the Caribbean.
And I must say I find your
thought very interesting.
And you touched on some
of the issues that I have.
I'm from the Caribbean as I said.
We have in the Caribbean, you know,
the University of the West Indies.
I come from a very small
island [inaudible] Dutch.
And I went to school [inaudible]
so I went to the Netherlands.
A lot of people in the school.
And they went to Paris.
I'm saying this to create a context
of what I'm going to ask you, right?
And you have touched on some
of the issues here, right?
This kind of -- and it
couldn't be otherwise.
You know, I've been in universities
all over America from USC and stuff
like that in Southern California.
The issue that we face obviously
in the world, and you have kind
of touched on that, is
the fact that, you know,
these research institutions
are fundamentally grounded
in the north, right?
Now we have a little bit China
starting to come, you know.
Actually, it has some
good universities.
Africa is still basically
nowhere, right?
A place that was colonized
by Europeans.
You have Oxford, Cambridge.
They could have easily have put
like Oxford and Cambridge in Africa.
Why didn't they do that?
Well, I think you can figure
out why they didn't do it
because it could lead
to intellectual competition,
et cetera, et cetera.
But this is a huge problem
for the world, right,
as the world globalizes, as
people become more world citizens.
And another big problem you
have, you didn't touch on it,
but universities came about
largely also in the West
as a handmaiden of
colonialism, right?
There was some criticism of it,
but it played a tremendous
central role in this whole process.
So the fact that a
lot of the knowledge
in the world right now is
dominated by the North, right,
told from a Northern perspective,
often with very problematical
view of other people, right?
I mean, you talked about the fact
and I'm very positive about that,
that, you know, there are
so many talented people,
you know -- not from the Caribbean.
I mean, Caribbean people have
been known to be talented.
But from Africa, Central
Latin America,
who simply are outed to the sea.
They have no chance to get
into these universities.
And the consequences of that for
the world as we go forward, right?
The need in essence, in essence
globalized that research institution
with all of the problems
that come along with that.
So I would like to hear some
of your thinking about it.
And also some of your thinking
of the limitations of the fact
that these research universities
have been in the North.
And a lot of the ideas have been
highly problematical for the South.
>> John Sexton: So, I'm going
to put aside a few of the very,
very big topics you raise because I
don't think they're necessary for me
to get to the heart [inaudible],
but I want to acknowledge
I'm putting them aside.
Western objectivism does not
capture all of reality, stipulated.
You know, I'm a PhD.
I've taught major religions,
North, South, all time periods.
I get it, okay?
So it's not all about the
Western perspective on the world.
That's the heart of my
ecumenical argument, okay?
So I accept that.
I don't want to get into
the history of colonialism
in the university and so forth.
I mean, that's a complex story.
I'm interested in looking to
the future from where we are.
And on that I agree with you
completely, which is that I've lived
through the experience
of NYU Abu Dhabi.
We're now -- we're up -- we're
building to 2000 undergraduates
and a thousand PhD students.
So 3000 students overall.
They are drawn literally
from around the world.
So there are 124 countries that are
represented, genuinely represented.
Not the children of expatriates
who live in Abu Dhabi.
But we're scouting
all around the world.
And Moosebah is not
an isolated example.
And the fact of the matter
is that they're running
with the best students in the world.
Okay? We've graduated less
than a thousand students.
In fact, I think it's only
about 700 students so far,
because we started off
with three small classes.
And we have six Rhodes Scholars
out of those 700 students.
And they've gone to Rhodes
Scholars and done very well.
They're proving your point in
a way when given the chance.
So the key thing becomes, how
do we get the change to them,
and how do we begin having a
genuinely ecumenical higher
education system?
And I accept that.
That's the response I
argue for on globalization.
And I think it's a
positive-sum game.
It is not a zero-sum game.
I think American universities
-- I mean, look.
America is noted for its
nativism and its chauvinism.
I think that those of ecumenism
would be very, very helpful.
And I -- if you look at my
14 years as President of NYU,
that's where we move
as a university.
So I don't disagree with you at all.
But I don't think dwelling
on the past and how we got
to where we are now is
particularly helpful.
>> My name is Rufus Game, a product
of the best schools in this country.
>> John Sexton: That must
be the Jesuit schools.
>> And [laughter].
Actually, one of them was.
And I'm now a judge --
>> John Sexton: Oh, you have to sit
down so they can see me while
you're asking your question
or moved to the side, Rufus.
That's a great idea.
>> Here we go.
>> John Sexton: But
it's a little hurtful.
I just succeeded as Jane
and Governor Patterson
and Jan will attest
-- I've just succeeded
on a 35-pound weightloss program
and a challenge form my kids.
They had actually named
my stomach Rufus.
But --
>> Ooh [laughter].
You know how to cut.
>> John Sexton: I'm -- no.
Go.
>> My sense, having gone
to the best schools,
that it is that at the very top,
schools have themselves kind
of figured it out, how to
line up a way to get people
who want to go there to go there.
But that really your -- the thrust
of your concern is working that back
down through the entire
array of schools.
And I -- if that's correct, I'd like
your comments on how do you spread
that so that the people
hoping to get
into some school have the same
opportunities that they would
at the best schools if people were
looking for them with scholarships.
>> John Sexton: Yeah.
So let me -- this is not
a dissenting opinion.
It's what we would call at the
Supreme Court, where Jan Hobley
and I worked together,
opinion concurring
in part and dissenting in part.
So I just want to put a
little caution flag up.
I think having been educated
at at least one Jesuit school
you'll probably accept this dialog
as a friendly amendment.
Speaking for one of the two or
three dozen most selected schools
in the country, you know, NYU, I'll
see we have not figured out how
to get a opportunity
down deep in society.
What we've figured out is how to
make ourselves extremely attractive
and to have people want us a lot,
and to get a sufficiently
diverse student body
that our consciences
are not shocked.
But I could give you story
after story after story.
I mean, I told you I've not
gone on for-profit boards.
Therefore, I've been a very
active member on various boards
that are consistent with the
message I'm giving you today.
And I'm on one board, for example,
that -- for a foundation --
relatively small, but it spends
a lot of effort and resources
out into places where
no one looks for kids.
And it pulls those kids in
and on three campuses --
Princeton, NYU, and Harvard --
it runs a five-week boot
camp for those kids.
And I think the average rise out
of 1600 on the SAT for the Kids,
and it's something like 80 to 100
kids that are in those boot camps,
the average rise is something like
450 points out of 1600 on the SAT,
proving that it is
eminently coachable.
But these kids never would have
gotten the coaching, right,
that in my city, people
routinely pay for, you know?
Hundreds of dollars an hour
they pay for the coaching.
So -- and those kids end up going
to the places that we would want
to send our kids, those schools
you're talking about, including NYU.
But they end up going only
because somebody has reached out,
discovered them, told them
it's important as a choice.
See, there's a whole lot of
information along the way that,
if we don't work systematically
as a society --
first, I'm saying there's
a big enough problem here
in the United States.
My life is now about raising the
standards for those tens of millions
of kids around the world.
That gets to this point
that was raised
with the first question, okay?
And -- because out there, I'm
telling you, there are students
that are as good as better than
the students that are going
to the schools that
you and I care about.
But they haven't been found.
And you know what?
They're smart.
And if we don't give them a
chance, if we don't give them hope,
they're going to get angry and
then you got smart angry people
out there.
And when you have not hundreds or
thousands or hundreds of thousands
or millions, but tens of millions
of smart angry people
out there, you know.
I got 1.2 million, 1.2
million Syrian kids in Turkey,
Lebanon, and Jordan, as we speak.
One point 2 million.
Syria had a pretty good education
system before 500 schools were
destroyed and they were
forced to flee their country.
Eight-five percent literacy rate.
But three years those
kids have been either
in the camps or on the street.
Seventy-five percent in the
camps, 25% in the streets,
getting no education at all.
They know what they're missing.
Now the sad thing is when I go
around and speak to governments
about helping that, when I speak to
the United States State Department,
the humanitarian argument
doesn't raise the dial very much.
The economic argument, it will be
good for -- raises [inaudible].
The security argument,
ehhh, ehhh, ehhh.
You know, now -- because you want to
know where the next people are going
to come from that are going
to be angry and smart enough
to do something about it?
So we got to get to this and
we got to get to it here.
But we got to get to it worldwide.
Yes, we have very,
very good schools.
And they're diverse.
But not enough.
>> Question [inaudible].
>> John Sexton: Yeah.
Thank you.
>> [Inaudible] I'm here.
>> John Sexton: Okay.
I'm sorry.
My answers are too long.
I apologize.
>> Yes, I know.
>> John Sexton: I'm sorry.
>> Thank you, Professor Sexton.
Actually, President Emeritus,
comma, Sexton, for this talk.
I was actually very touched by
some of the comments you made.
But actually some [inaudible] and
also -- but not for your own fault.
But my name is John del Pino.
I'm now 47 years old.
But back in 1988/'89 I wrote
about some of these very issues
that you talked about at, again, one
of the leading research institutions
in the world -- I would
argue the best in the world,
the University of Chicago.
At the time I was President of
the Hispanic Student Association.
And, ironically, I've been rereading
something I wrote back then,
even before your talk.
I didn't know you were
touching these issues.
I wrote a series of essays back
then in April, May, and June.
1990, called "What is the Future
of the Spanish [inaudible]
our Education?
And I'm more happy to
share with you later on.
But it was published actually
in Chicago [inaudible] in which
in a six-part series of essays,
I talked about these very
themes that you talked about.
Unfortunately, not through any
lack of neglect on your part,
but it seems like kind of sad to
me how you regress to much more
than I would have anticipated on
some very topics that you raised,
whether it's some of
these kids you mentioned
about who make their last grasp for
education at high school diplomas
or lack of access information,
whether [inaudible] of poor schools
or a lack of being fully engaged in
access information by having parents
who necessarily might not be
engaged in the total process.
Unlike our communities in
the U.S. are more aware
of simply knowledge
and opportunities.
Not through any of these deliberate
design but just simply by awareness.
And also by somewhat
political neglect
and sometimes almost
by deliberateness.
As [inaudible] you know, the recent
statistics about there's more --
regresses more [inaudible] in
some parts of the country now.
And for lack of time,
I just want [inaudible]
by saying I really applaud you
for having the courage
to raise these issues.
I certainly hope an ideal
situation we can really fully
progress further.
I know for one I've not given
up thinking about these issues.
And I for one am fully proud
[inaudible] my institution,
many others around the world.
You also [inaudible]
others to continue
to encourage the life of the mind.
And with all due respect
to the first gentleman,
I think these very issues that
I became aware at the University
of Chicago and elsewhere, when I've
not fully been aware throughout my
knowledge of history
and to men of courage.
I'm going to encourage to help them.
Try to push the ball further
down the field so to speak.
And I applaud you for them.
Like you said, let's not
dwell too much on the past.
Let's try to go forward.
But also learning -- minding of
the certain lessons of the past.
And [inaudible] tonight, I
said, to paraphrase, you know,
not to repeat the same mistakes.
We try to learn from
and move forward.
Thank you very much.
>> John Sexton: Thank you, Joh.
It's a good place to close.
I'll just use your comments to
just connect the dots once again
in case I've not made myself clear.
So I began by talking about
three topics that we could talk
about outside of the
context of higher education.
You know, what you see in our
civic and political discourse --
I mean, just remember, the
Hirschman quote I read was 1991.
The Edwards example I gave was 2004.
I didn't give any from this year.
You're living it.
Go home and watch Sports Center
tonight [laughter], okay?
And see what we've done.
But what it is, what
it is, you understand,
that we may be witnessing is
the death of thought, right?
I mean, if we just
continue to devalue thought
and put aside whether it's good
or bad for research universities.
It's obviously bad.
But it's not good for society.
It's not good.
You know, we were put on
Earth as homosapiends, right?
I mean, it's -- so then you see
that the university can be
an antidote to this, right?
And it's quixotic.
But it can be an antidote to it.
Then you move to globalization and,
again, it's an unavoidable thing.
I mean, you know, the
phenomena that are working
out are just what [inaudible] de
Jardin spoke about in the 1940's.
So the world is coming together.
Now are we going to come
together and cause a combustion,
or are we going to come together and
create a community of communities?
Again, this is a very big question.
Again, higher education has
a key role to play in it.
And then you get to technology
and technology is not the enemy
of what we're trying to do here.
It's -- I don't worry
about it being disruptive.
It's not going to disrupt.
It's going to change many
different parts of the orchestra.
And if we use it right, it will
democratize higher education
as long as we have ladders up.
Okay? But it can't be used to stamp
other people's kids with a BA degree
and declare a political victory.
That's the danger, you see.
That's the danger.
It's that it runs down the value.
And, you know, oh, look, our
college graduation rates are up.
And then the final element that I
meant is meant to tie it together.
And this is, John, the
point that you're making.
And I tie it back positively
to the point
that was made out of the Caribbean.
For me, it's a moral issue.
For the, the humanitarian
argument is enough.
You cannot waste a
mind that's out there.
And I've lived it because I
teach these kids in Abu Dhabi.
And I'm telling you it's
an amazing thing to see.
And they -- and to know that
the Moosebah's and the Teyho's
and the others would
have had nothing
because they never
would have been found
and they never would have
known it made a difference.
And then to see the Syrian kids and
they know it makes a difference.
So it's not enough.
This is where the flavor of
Rawlsianism has to come in.
And it was my last, my kind of
punchline that pulls it together.
As we think about the --
elevating civic discourse
and embracing globalization and
utilizing technology to the maximum,
it's only going to work if
we generalize it in a way
that we don't know where, you know,
in the Rawls Table
we're sitting, you know?
And it works for everybody
at the table.
And that requires a fairly
massive investment of resources
because the education that we want
at those best schools, by the way,
is -- and I'll just close
by recommending a book --
Why Does College Cost So Much ?
Okay? Why Does College
Cost So Much ?
And it's because in a
well-functioning economy,
a high-talent service industry goes
up more rapidly than inflation.
So then the only question
becomes, okay,
if it's the cost that's
going up, what's the subsidy?
And cost minus subsidy equals price.
And it doesn't require a
rocket scientist to figure
out if you withdraw subsidy
and cost is going up,
price is going to go up.
Or quality is going to go down.
So we, you know, we got
to get out of this kind
of very simple minded
debate that, you know --
and it all works synergistically
to me because that's
when the demagogue can say to
those who are allergic to nuance
and complexity, your
costs are going up.
So the solution is what?
Give everybody -- freeze tuition.
Okay, freeze tuition.
I'll go on record right now and
say that is a stupid policy.
Freezing tuition gives Donald Trump
and William Gates's
children scholarships.
Okay? It doesn't make sense.
But it's hard to -- there will be
another talk to explain that to you.
But I'm telling you, that's
not the good social policy.
And we got to get to
ourselves to a point
where these four things are
working together positively.
And then we can have a
world that we're proud of.
It's not going to happen
in my lifetime,
but it will happen
in Jane's, I'm sure.
All right.
Thank you all very, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane McAuliffe: Thank you
President Sexton and thank you
to all of you who were
here this afternoon
for this lecture at
the Kluge Center.
We do have refreshments for you.
I hope the conversation
will continue.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.